[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome to Google.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Thank
you for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
very happy to have you.
You are actually from
Nashville, Tennessee.
Is that right?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Correct.
Yeah, my mother's from
Brazil, Rio de Janeiro.
My dad's from the Ozarks,
but I grew up in Nashville.
MALE SPEAKER: So
Nashville's a town
that has a very rich
musical history.
Did that have any
influence on you
in terms of steering
you towards music?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Yeah, I
think Nashville definitely
rubbed off on me because, one,
it's just a rich musical town.
Everybody I know whose father,
uncle was in the music biz
or something like that.
And then it's just a
rich musical history.
So we've got a lot of
really good record shops
in Nashville that you can
find rare records that were
significant to that region.
Specifically, stuff that
was recorded in Nashville
like old gospel, soul,
blues albums that you really
couldn't find anywhere else.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you remember
the first record you bought?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
The first record
I bought, I think it was like
a Mexican bullfight record.
But most of my
record collection,
honestly, is hand me downs
from people, people that'd just
call me up, be like,
hey, my dad's giving away
all his old records.
I know you're into hip
hop and so-- you know,
a lot of my collection
is $0.99 dollar
been records, hand-me downs.
And it ends up
forcing you to be more
creative because
those types of records
aren't necessarily meant
for sample, or you know,
you wouldn't actually think to
sample those kind of records.
But yeah, another big influence
for me in Nashville growing up
was the Vanderbilt station,
WRVU, which is now shut down.
But when I was growing
up, that was home
to a lot of good radio
shows such as Ken Berryhill.
He had a show called "The
Old-Time Record Shop"
and "The Old Jazz Boy" that I
used to listen to on the way
to college every day.
And those would always put me
on to all types of old jazz
and blues that I
had never heard of.
And then another show that
was really influential for me,
and a lot of other
Nashvillians at the time,
was the "911
Emergency Show" hosted
by DJ Egon and Count Basie.
And so that show was really
influential for anybody
in Nashville who listened
to hip hop at that time.
They would play hip hop
in breaks and samples
and kind of connect the dots for
people and show the evolution,
kind of like what
I'm doing today.
And so that was a huge influence
me growing up, as well,
and living in Nashville.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
So beyond just having a
musical city to grow in,
you actually grew up
in a musical household.
For those of you who
don't know, your dad
is actually a jazz trumpeter.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: What was
it was like growing up
in El Buho's house.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: It was awesome.
Growing up, I was always
surrounded by music
and virtuoso musicians.
And it's funny because
it really didn't
dawn on me until I got older
how legendary and virtuoso
these guys actually were, and
so you start to appreciate
that as you get older.
But yeah, growing
up I was always
surrounded by samplers
and beat machines,
and I spent summers
at my dad's, just
going through his jazz records
and listening to records
and messing around with,
like, old synthesizers.
And I think that
definitely rubbed off.
When I was 17, my dad
took me on tour with him
with his band in
Colorado, and that
was a really big eye-opening
experience for me.
It was my first official
time going out on the road,
touring in real venues,
using real equipment.
And so that was definitely an
invaluable experience for me
too.
MALE SPEAKER: So what was your
road from there to here like?
Like, how did you
figure out-- like, what
did you come to music
motivated by, like,
would did you want
to get out of it?
And then how did
you figure out what
you needed to know and pursue
learning all of those things
to fill the gaps to be able
to do this type of thing
that you're doing now?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well, I
started dabbling with music
when I was pretty young, like
I said, when I was a kid,
I was just messing around with
keyboards and synthesizers.
And when I was about,
I guess, 13 or so,
I started working at my
friend's computer shop.
And he taught me how
to build computers,
and so I got really
nerdy, into software,
and putting together
computer parts.
And eventually, that led to me
getting my hands on some DAW
software for producing.
And then after that I got
my first set of turntables,
started buying records.
But I was into music
long before I even
started thinking about
hip hop or mashups
and I was even
producing long before I
started doing these
conceptual collaborations.
You know, I was
just creating beats
in my bedroom and kind of
honing my skills over time.
And then back in 2009,
2010, my friend and I
started this DJ crew called
Bebop and Rocksteady,
based on the Ninja Turtles
super villains, if you guys are
familiar.
But anyway, you know,
it was basically
like a mashup, kind of your
basic cut and paste mashup
style.
So where you just take one
track or an instrumental
in an acapella and
put them together,
and we had a lot of
success with that.
We had a good couple years DJing
around Nashville, doing that,
and people really dug it.
But with the Soul
Mates project, I
wanted to take
that a step further
and start to dig a little deeper
and actually, like I said,
try to recreate studio
sessions between these artists,
and make it sound more authentic
and not like it was just cut
and paste.
And so that's kind
of the evolution
of how I got to where I am.
MALE SPEAKER: So with so
many different exposures
that you had
growing up, is there
anything that stands
out to you as something
that was sort of one of the more
valuable or more inspirational
experiences that
you had as a child?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Like
I said, just witnessing
all the virtuoso musicians
and my dad, going to his shows
and accompanying him.
And I think just being around
that in general, you know,
it seeps into you.
And, like I said,
the older you get,
the more you start to
appreciate those experiences.
At the time, I was just a kid
just having fun. (SELF MOCKING)
Oh, this is fun music.
Now that I look
back on it, those
experiences definitely
shaped who I am today.
But I think my biggest influence
and inspiration is just
the art of discovery and going
to the record store and digging
through old records and getting
my hands dusty and reading
the liner notes.
And, you know, that's
what inspires me.
I get inspired by others or
listening to like a Pete Rock
beat and noticing the
sample and then figuring
out it's Fela Kuti.
And then who's Fela Kuti,
and then doing my research
and then eventually creating
a whole project based
around that, so
I think discovery
is what I thrive
on as an artist.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sure
these guys want to discover
some more of your work.
But before we get into the
next demo, I have to ask,
you've been on tour
since you were young.
You're on tour now.
What is the craziest thing
that you've experienced while
on tour?
Like, what is the
standout moment?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well, I went on
tour with this cannabis culture
website called 420 RAW,
and it was a spring break
tour that was pretty crazy.
You know, we're rolling
around in this huge bus
with 420 written
on the side of it,
getting pulled over by
border patrol every day.
And so that was a very
unique experience.
But no, being on
the road's crazy.
You know, to me it's
just crazy that I'm
on the road and the fact
that, like, I just got back
from Europe in December, and the
fact that I could go to Germany
or Switzerland and
people actually
know who I am and are paying
money to come see me perform,
get their records signed.
That's like the greatest
feeling in the world and truly
blessing, so I'm very
thankful to be where I am.
MALE SPEAKER: Right
now, you're best known
for your fictional
collaborations.
One of the tracks
from Yasiin Gaye
was just picked up for--
I know you guys have seen
it-- the Apple-iPod TV spots.
We should play it afterwards.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
Yeah, we can do that.
MALE SPEAKER: But
you do so much more.
How do you compare a work
like "Selective Hearing"
or the track that you just
produced for The Pharcyde
to more of these
collabos that people
seem to be very excited about?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Yeah, well,
with "Selective Hearing,"
that was my first album
that I released in 2010.
That was kind of an
instrumental trip hop,
hip hop album, and so with
"Selective Hearing," that's
kind of what the title implies.
I have selective hearing, and
so that's the natural process
that I go through when
I listen to music,
is I take the parts
that I like the most
and reinterpret them
in my own way and so,
for me, "Selective Hearing"
is a little more personal,
gives me a little more freedom
to just go anywhere and go
to different places of music.
Whereas with a conceptual
collaboration like Yasiin Gaye
or Bizarre Tribe or Fela
Soul, it's less about me
and it's more about the artists
and helping tailor the project
to help tell their
story and, like I said,
make it sound as if
they were actually
in the studio
collaborating together.
So I think that's the
biggest difference
between Selective Hearing and
the conceptual collaborations.
MALE SPEAKER: So with
the collaborations,
are there any combinations
that stand out
as either much harder
than you expected or much,
much easier than they would
have seemed on the surface?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
All the ones I've
done so far have just come
really easy and naturally,
and that's what's beautiful
about it is you just get lucky.
And a lot of the
time, I'm never really
sure if it's going to
work out when I start,
and so I'll spend a lot of time
just researching and listening
to the catalogs and
then connecting the dots
and then trying to find
those overlaps before I even
begin to start
remixing or sampling
or chopping anything up.
And yes, so with Yasiin Gaye
it just kind of unfolded
so naturally.
You know, there were
so many similarities
between Mos Def and Marvin
Gaye's music and so many parts
where they could kind
of create a conversation
where it seemed as though they
were talking to one another.
And I guess it helps that Mos
Def is a huge Marvin Gaye fan,
so he mentions him in
his songs, and there's
a lot of overlap there.
But--
MALE SPEAKER: You
also have a couple
that are not necessarily obvious
like, for example, "Ghostface
Thriller."
Where were you?
What did you have for breakfast?
[LAUGHTER]
Like, how did that
come together?
Like, what was the
[INAUDIBLE] process there?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well,
"Ghostface Thriller"
is kind of a Halloween,
just, novelty try.
It's not like a
conceptual collaboration,
so don't get excited.
There's not going to be a
"Ghostface Thriller" album
or anything like that.
But Halloween's my--
MALE SPEAKER: I'm out.
[LAUGHTER]
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: You
know, Halloween's one
of my favorite
holidays, so I really
just want something I could
play at the next Halloween
party I DJ at.
One thing cool about
"Ghostface Thriller"
was that I actually found this
unreleased recording floating
around on the internet
of Michael Jackson
and Vincent Price in the
studio together clowning around
before they actually
did the takes.
And so you hear a little
bit of that in the beginning
of "Ghostface Thriller."
You know, they're
like, how do I say it?
Do I say it like, (WHISPERS)
thriller, thriller, am
I supposed to say it like that?
You can hear my Michael
Jackson, and then there's
also Vincent's rap.
Vincent Price has like
a secret third verse
that nobody's ever really heard,
and so I was able to find that.
MALE SPEAKER: How do you
find all these things?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
I'm just a nerd.
I live and breathe this
stuff, so like I said,
discovery is just
what I thrive on.
MALE SPEAKER: So
the right answer
would have been at
Google search but--
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
Google I use daily.
MALE SPEAKER:
Speaking of Google,
so Google is a technology,
and a lot of folks
are interested in the
technology that you use
and how you apply technology.
What software, hardware,
other aspects of technologies
you find sort of most useful
for the work that you do?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well,
one thing that I've
come to realize over
the years of being a DJ
and touring and
being out on the road
is that the turntable
itself is still relevant.
And that's something
that I don't
think it's going to
go-- it's irreplaceable.
You know, I've tried a lot
of different DJ controllers
and launch pads and MIDI
controllers and stuff
for DJing.
And at the end of
the day, I always
come back to the turntable.
There's nothing like the
satisfaction and the freedom
and the control you
have with the turntable,
manipulating a vinyl record.
And so I think that will always
be a significant part of what
I do.
As far as software goes, I'm
a big fan of Ableton Live.
And one of the main features
in Ableton Live that
allows me to do what I do is
it's time stretch and warping
capabilities.
So in Ableton Live, you
can take a sample-- usually
when you're playing a
sample on a turntable
and you speed it up, it
sounds like a chipmunk.
If you slow it down, it
sounds chopped and screwed.
With Ableton Live, I can
prevent that from happening,
and so I can slow down
a sample while still
maintaining the tone of
someone's voice or vice versa.
I can pitch it up without
changing the speed of it,
and so that feature alone
is a very significant part
of mashing things up
and warping things
into place so that they all
lock in and fit in the grid
perfectly.
And so, Yeah, Ableton Live
is definitely a huge part
of what I do as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Do
you think there's
anything that is lacking in the
technology that's available?
So like, let's say you
had a fairy-god nerd that
would grant you
whatever your whish was,
what would you wish for?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: I really
want a talk box or a vocoder.
I think that'd be
pretty cool, but--
MALE SPEAKER: Something
that doesn't exist.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
Yeah, well I mean,
I think as far as technology,
we've come a really long way.
And there's, essentially,
unlimited amounts of options
that you can do now that
you couldn't even do before,
and so the options
are pretty limitless.
And it can be
overwhelming at times,
and so I'm glad I
came up during an era
where I was still bound
by certain limitations
because I think that
encourages-- limitations
encourage creativity.
And so it makes me appreciate
the technology even more.
But yeah, if I had
one wish, I think
it would be for the industry
and the copyright laws
to adapt to the technology that
we have because, like I said,
we have everything
we need and it's just
a matter of us working
together to try to come up
with a better solution.
And so if companies like
Pandora and Spotify,
streaming companies
that are already
paying for the licensing for
these tracks to stream online,
you know, if they were to
extend that license for people
like me to come along and
remix and reinterpret and then
have those remixes available for
streaming on the same service.
Something like
that, I think, could
benefit, not only the original
artist, but the record labels,
the publishers, and even
give people more incentive
to subscribe to the service
and also hopefully introduced
new generations to
this music, which
is a big part of
what I do as well.
MALE SPEAKER: So we have mics
at the end of either aisle
if anyone wants to come up
and ask Amerigo any questions.
And while you guys
are getting set,
you are a mere 28 years old,
and you've done quite a bit.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: 29 actually.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, did
you-- happy birthday.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: No, I have
to think about that too.
MALE SPEAKER: One more year.
What's next for you?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well, I
just got confirmed for South
by Southwest in Austin.
I'm really excited about that.
As far as new projects, I like
to keep things under wrap,
so I can't really
speak on that just yet.
But I will probably be
premiering a song or two
from my next project
at South by Southwest,
so stay tuned for that.
And I'm also working on a
soulful EP with a singer
vocalist by the name of
Xiomara Grace Watson, which
you can check out
some of her stuff
at Xiomaramusic.com,
with an x, Xiomara.
MALE SPEAKER: You also
have a show coming up.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Oh, I
have a show on Sunday
with George Clinton,
Funkadelic, P-Funk in Philly,
so super excited about that.
And yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Questions?
AUDIENCE: OK, I'll start.
Back in the day, I used to
DJ for students and student
parties.
I encountered my first mashup.
It was Madison Avenue with
Blur, "Don't Call Me Song 2,"
and my head just like blew up.
It was like playing two
songs where people, you
could see them like
going in one direction.
And then suddenly, like,
the other song showed up,
and it was fantastic like to
see the reactions of the people.
At that point, I
realized that that
was like a totally new genre.
It's going to like bring some
new like music, like you do.
But at the same time,
I realized that like it
could lead to a situation in
which, like, with copyright
laws like they're
introducing right now,
it was going to be a
disaster for a lot of people.
Because fair use and sampling,
it has always been like a--
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Slippery slope.
AUDIENCE: --slippery slope,
like a really thin line
on the ground that you'd never
know when you're crossing
or not.
But have you, like you mentioned
it before, but have you
encountered any
of those problems?
Like, releasing your
albums, do you always
have to do like
agreements with people
or have you just,
like, released things
and then, like, figured
out that the FBI was, like,
knocking on your door?
What is your
experience with that?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Not the FBI.
But yeah, we've received a lot
of opposition to our projects.
"Bizarre Tribe" is
no longer available
online or for
distribution, and so we've
had a lot of uphill
battles in terms of that.
But we just do it anyway
because this is something
that I'm passionate
about doing, and the fans
are passionate about it.
And it's something that, I
think if given the opportunity
to exist, I think people
see the value in it.
So like with the
Apple commercial,
I think that was a huge
breakthrough for us
because, you know, we've
been getting cease and desist
letters up until now, and so
when we were able to work out
the deal with the
Apple commercial,
Apple pays for the licensing.
Interscope released
the single on iTunes.
All the content owners
and artists got paid,
and I think that in itself
is proof that what I do
is a valuable art form
and transformative
and also can potentially lead to
profit for the original content
owners.
And so I think that's
one of the things
that we're trying to
demonstrate with what we do so.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Quick follow up and
also a different question.
Quick follow up, the friction
between artists and labels,
right?
Labels are the main people
that are getting pissed
that you're taking
their stuff and then
chopping it up and mixing
it with other stuff.
Are they just being
overprotective in your opinion?
I mean, as an artist, you
have the same kind of "I need
to get paid" concerns as any
other artist would hopefully,
so the fact that the labels are
going after people, you know,
are they just being greedy?
Who's wrong in this situation?
I'm just curious to
hear your opinion.
I mean, obviously there's no
one person clearly in the wrong,
otherwise people would
have done something,
but I'm curious to your opinion.
And then also who
you grew up-- why hip
hop, why hip hop in general?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Yeah, I
mean, I respect their right.
You know, like they
definitely have a right
to protect what they own.
And I'm not really on
the side of just screw
the record labels.
I really would like
to get to the point
where we can negotiate
and come to agreements.
Like, the Apple is an
example and yeah, I mean,
I think there's just a
lot of things-- a lot
of room for negotiation
that hasn't really--
those bridges haven't
really been crossed yet.
And so if anything, by
putting these projects out,
quote unquote, "illegally," it
gets people talking about it,
and it gets the
conversation going.
And, you know, I may
not have the solution,
but if I can get everyone
in this room and a bunch
of other people thinking about
it and on their minds then
maybe we can come up
with a solution that
benefits everybody, myself,
the artist, the record labels.
And so it's really
just about creating
awareness for what I do and the
value and impact that it has.
What was your other--
AUDIENCE: Why hip hop?
I was curious.
I mean, Nashville
was a great-- it's
got sort of a
logical progression
from blues, soul,
disco, funk, and now
we finally have hip hop, but
I don't think of Nashville,
right now, as a leading city
in the hip hop industry.
So I'm curious how
you got into that.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Well, shout
out to my brother Ricky.
He's over there.
He put me on to a lot of
hip hop when I was younger.
When I was younger, I found
this old shoebox full a cassette
tapes when he left for college,
and none of the cassette tapes
were in the shoe box, but it was
all album covers, Gang Starr,
Souls of Mischief, De La Soul.
And so at the time,
I just started
buying these tapes
on impulse, you know,
repurchasing these albums
and listening to them.
And then, like I said, WRVU,
the radio show, "911 Emergency"
with DJ Egon and Count Basie
was also a big influence for me
at the time, putting
me on to hip hop
and getting my gears
turning for hip hop.
But like I said,
hip hop is what--
it was really the opposite.
You know, I was into
hip hop, and then
that led me to discover
disco and funk and soul
and blues and jazz
and really dig deeper
into all those
other genres, and so
that's why I've
always considered
hip hop an important
tool for learning
and a tool for music
discovery through sampling.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool,
thanks for stopping by.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate it.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Yep, outside
of the legal issues
that you guys encounter
with the examples and stuff,
when an artist like Mos Def
actually does hear the mashup,
do you ever get any response
from them like this is sick?
This is amazing?
MALE SPEAKER: You get
asked to produce a track.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: We've gotten
a lot of feedback from,
you know, Talib
Kweli shouted us out.
Janis Gaye recently
mentioned in an interview,
they asked her what-- if
she had any favorite remixes
or reinterpretations,
and she brought me up.
And The Pharcyde, I was able
to collaborate with them
and perform with them
at South by Southwest.
And so, as he mentioned,
a lot of times
the artists are
in support of it.
It's just the labels and
the actual publishers
and content owners
that are opposed to it,
and so, yeah, we've gotten a lot
of support from artists so far.
AUDIENCE: And then also,
I have two more questions.
First, do you have any shows?
Are you performing while
you're in the city?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: No, I'm playing
in Philly on Sunday with George
Clinton and P-Funk, but
hopefully I'll be back in New
York soon doing some gigs so--
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
And then the tracks that
you, that you actually
can separate the
samples like the locals
from the cores and the drums.
How do you actually get
access to that fragmented
form of the track?
AMERIGO GAZAWAY:
Just the internet.
I'm not really-- I don't
really want to tell you where
because I want it to still
exist for other people tomorrow.
But also there's, for instance,
the game "Rock Band" or "Guitar
Hero," those games
actually have a lot
of the multi tracks for all
those songs broken down.
So you, you know, when
people are playing the game,
they're adding the multi tracks
just like I was, one by one.
And so a lot of those actually
came from those games,
a lot of the multi tracks, but
there's also a handful of them
floating out there.
And in the '90s, you
know, and earlier on, it
was more commonplace
for vinyl singles
to have instrumentals and
acappellas and dub edits
and stuff like
that on the record.
Now that, I guess, because of
remixing has become so rampant
and people are trying to
curb that, they're not
doing it as much, but a
lot of the older stuff,
you can still find
acappellas for multi track.
And so I'm always on
the hunt for stuff
like because it really
changes, you know, the options
and what's available-- I
can really dig in a lot more
when I have those isolated
stems than when I'm just working
with the individual song so.
AUDIENCE: Yep, cool.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Last
question, over here.
AUDIENCE: Who are you listening
to now, not old stuff,
but current artists.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Current
artists, I guess not current,
Prince.
I've been listening to
the new Prince album,
and the new D'Angelo
is also a really good,
"Black Messia," and Big KRIT.
Being from the south, I'm
a huge fan of southern rap,
and so I've been listening
to his new album,
"Cadillactica" a lot.
But a lot of funk stuff.
I'm really excited
for "Tuxedo," which
is John Mayer or, not John
Mayer, Mayer Hawthorne, excuse
me, Mayer Hawthorne
and Jake One.
And what else?
Run the Jewels, I've
been listening to a lot,
but yeah, that's probably
what's on my iPod right now.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, great.
Hey, it's been great
hanging out with you.
Thank you.
AMERIGO GAZAWAY: Thank
you guys for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
Big round of applause.
Amerigo Gazaway.